it's been a year since 20 indian troops
and at least four chinese soldiers
died in a deadly border clash in india's
north but the standoff in the karakoram
mountains
that led to the clash continues that
skirmish in the galwan valley
occurred on the more than 000 kilometer
long mostly
un-demarcated border between the two
asian giants
both claimed transgressions into each
other's territory
at various points a massive troop
build-up from both sides
followed earlier this year troops did
pull back
from one of those points and that point
was further south
in pangong lake that was in february
but since then talks to have troops pull
back from other areas such as in gogra
hot springs and the depsang plains have
not changed the situation on the ground
here's more
high in the karakoram ranges jagged
cliffs
saw above the galwan valley these
satellite images show the disputed
region where indian and chinese troops
clashed
a year ago soldiers confronted each
other
then attacked with rocks and clubs in
what was their first
fatal confrontation since 1975
the clash killed 20 indian soldiers
while the chinese government claimed
only four of theirs were killed
but it was the most serious face-off
between the two nuclear-armed neighbors
in nearly half a century
and both sides blamed each other
[Applause]
the entire country is hurt and angry
at the steps taken by china at the line
of actual control
the border the clashes triggered an
ongoing wave of anti-china sentiment in
india
and a ban on an array of chinese apps
including tick tock and wechat
but china said it was merely defending
its territorial integrity
shockingly on june 15th indian troops
seriously violated the bilateral
consensus and crossed the border line
twice engaging in illegal activities and
provoking
and attacking chinese personnel
resulting in serious physical
confrontation
between border forces on the two sides
china and india have a history of
face-offs along this yellow line
known as the line of actual control it's
not a hard border since china and india
have never actually agreed on where
it should lie but the ongoing
competition between them to build
infrastructure along it
continues to heighten tensions the two
militaries agreed in february
to pull back from the mountains around
the contested pangong lake
but china has so far refused to withdraw
from the other areas it has occupied
and india's ministry of external affairs
says the process of disengagement
remains unfinished
joining me now for more is defense
analyst and journalist
ajay shukla ajay what is the situation
on the ground
now well the situation
remains pretty much the same there has
not been a great
degree of disengagement and pullback by
either the chinese or the indians
there is one sector and that is it's
called the pangong lake sector
where a mutual disengagement and
pullback
has been agreed to but there are still
three more sectors
uh from the north counting down
uh the depsang plane uh the galwan
valley
and also further south towards dem choc
where the chinese have not pulled back
the indians have also
deployed forward now and to that extent
uh there's you can call it a token
disengagement
but the troops remain in contact troops
are facing up the dangers
of inadvertent escalation still continue
and to that extent it's not a very happy
situation on the line of control or the
line of actual control i should say
in ladakh uh does that mean that any
hopes that chinese forces will vacate
the areas that india wants them to
vacate are misplaced
well yes by by the looks of it they've
been in occupation of these areas
for more than a year now uh they have
not uh
been willing to discuss uh disengagement
from these areas
in the senior military officers border
talks that take place
periodically so by the looks of it uh
the chinese
seem to be saying that where we have
disengaged from where we want to
disengage
but the rest of the the areas where we
are in occupation
uh are chinese territory so it's it's
very much
a sort of a process of getting by
steady steadily creeping forward and
remaining in occupation
of those territories uh eventually they
just become chinese territories uh
after a few years i'm wondering then
just trying to expand this uh to the
region
what is the takeaway from this india
china standoff that has lasted more than
a year now
for countries in asia that also have
territorial disputes with china
well it's it's a very clear lesson isn't
it
just as they have done in the south
china sea
uh they have drawn a sort of an
arbitrary
unilateral nine dash line in 11-9
and they steadily come into possession
of islands and nettles by building
military infrastructure
in the areas that they claim they're
doing much the same thing in ladakh
they've come forward they've taken
occupation of the areas that they claim
and they're pretty much centered sending
out the signal that we're not
withdrawing from here this is chinese
territory
so there's there is a clear parallel
between the south china sea
uh except that that's in a maritime
context
and here on the land border in ladakh
honestly speaking ajay countries in the
region don't prepare to really have an
answer to this to these kinds of chinese
actions too there
oh no the only sort of difference that
you have here in this case
is that the indian army albeit belatedly
uh sort of went up occupied faced off
against the chinese
uh and sort of let the signal be known
that they will not allow any further
uh sort of a creeping possession by
china of indian claimed territory
so uh while in the south china sea china
is pretty much
getting a free run in the land border
the indian side has sort of put its foot
down and said that we are not letting
you get in possession of any more indian
territory
so uh it's it's uh it's a sort of a
nasty situation
but chinese uh sort of military planning
uh sort of seems to be okay with that
kind of nastiness
as long as they get what they want they
get by
by occupying those territories they're
quite okay with it
ajeshla we leave it there for the time
being but thank you so much for joining
us
thank you my pleasure